usually the pound is at like one pound  would buy you 1.30 now one pound will  buy you almost a dollar which is  absolutely insane this is because the  Federal Reserve is increasing interest  rates so that strengthens the dollar  that's quantitative tightening kind of  reversing what they previously did  everything is artificially induced the  energy crisis everything in the UK as a  result they're printing more money to  try fix the issue which printing money  did so it's a mess right now I really  expect that the Euro the pound and the  dollar will all hit one for one we all  get on to one Global Currency which is  the dollar once we're all on the same  currency remember if you control the  mind you control the world we now have  one Central Bank which controls the  entire world um and then they crash the  dollar so they [ __ ] us all basically and  move us onto something called a central  bank digital